la caq a présenté son cadre financier
samedi matin on vous en parlait hier en
détail à l'émission en résumé ce cadre
qui prévoit près de 30 milliards de
dollars de nouveaux engagements sur
quatre ans notamment une baisse d'impôt
qui sera financée par des versements
moins élevé dans le fonds des
générations
la caq prévoit un déficit budgétaire de
7 milliards 700 millions de dollars
cette année au lieu de 1 milliard 700
millions tel que prévu dans le rapport
pré électorale retour à l'équilibré
prévu en 2027 28 alors dans le cadre de
nos entrevues sur les cadres financiers
nous avons reçu le candidat dans groupe
pour la cac eric girard en milieu
d'après midi
monsieur girard bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous de nous parler de votre
cadre financier que vous avez pu
présenter donc en fin de semaine j'avais
l'impression en regardant votre carte
financier que c'était le retour des
déficits structurels dont vous nous
aviez parlé vouloir vous débarrasser on
s'en est débarrassé la croissance
économique la croissance de l'inflation
faisait qu'on était presque revenu à
l'équilibré budgétaire est ce que vous
nous proposez de revenir au déficit
structurel
non parce qu'il faut bien comprendre une
campagne électorale c'est l'équivalent
de quatre budgets savait que ces sont
les engagements pour futurs mandats et
donc on a l'eau la somme des engagements
qui pourrait correspondre à 84 budget
est dans notre camp on a toujours dit
qu'on revenait à l'équilibré budgétaire
27 28 au sens comptable on est en
surplus en 26 27 alors c'est vraiment
une proposition qui est prudente
équilibrée responsable
est ce que c'est vraiment prudent la
prudence qui était vraiment un
qualificatif qu'on vous a collé on était
revenu pratiquement à l'équilibré
budgétaire vous nous ramenez en déficit
des déficits de 5 à 7 milliards dans les
prochaines années mais d'abord il ya une
mesure temporaire qui vient aider
immédiatement les gens parce que la
hausse du coût de la vie c'est
maintenant qu'elle est
quelques son effet au maximum et
lorsqu'on dépense 3.5 milliards dans
l'année courante c'est certain que le
déficit augmente alors on est cohérent
avec nos actions mais nous avons
toujours dit d'y revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire 27-28 c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons et on continue de réduire
le poids de la dette et le donc les
éléments clés sont la réduction du
fardeau fiscal préfinancement
principalement financement des
principales missions de l'état et qu'il
est budgétaire réduction du poids des
équilibres budgétaires dans sept ans
plus de déficit en moins dans cinq ans
27 28
7 28 le 5 septembre le temps d'annoncer
cinq années fiscales le prochain il a
neigé budget 23 24 ok parfait je
comprends mais malgré tout donc plus de
déficit au cours des prochaines années
moins d'argent dans le fonds des
générations donc du rendement perdu sur
les versements qui répliquent fait dans
le fonds des générations est encore là
je suis pas d'accord avec votre
affirmation parce que le le fond les
générations a été créé en 2006 pour la
ce moment là ont contribué des centaines
de millions pas des milliards cette
année on va verser plus de 3 milliards
les versements étaient prévus augmente
if 4,5 milliards d'un alors lorsqu'on
prend si les augmentations qui était
prévu puis aux finances les réductions
d'impôts avec soin à chacun mais quoi la
permet de s'assurer que les missions de
l'état santé éducation sont bien
financés mais avec l'argent des
prochaines générations
le fonds des générations c'est de
l'équité intergénérationnelle les
générations vis à réduire le poids de la
dette exact c'est exactement ce que nous
allons continuer de faire le détenait
par rapport au pib 38 % au 31 mars 2022
nous visons 31 % en deux ans 31 mars
2000 trader si on attendait nos
objectifs sur la dette pourquoi ne pas
cesser de collecter les revenus des
dixons au fonds des générations faut
changer la loi on va changer la loi bien
sûr on va on va réduire les montants qui
sont dédiés au fonds des générations
pour éviter que les revenus parce que
les versements augmentent de 3,5
millions pour maintenir les versements
autour de 3 millions est ce que vous
voulez gardez le fonds des générations
ceux où changer la loi pu mettre fin au
fonds des générations
on ya personne que par l'oni d'éliminer
le fonds des générations pour la
question non on regarde on ne dit que
nous allions modifier la loi d'abord le
fond comme tel et toujours capitaliser
je pense à 6,6 milliards de dollars
actuellement les versements prévus sont
de 3 milliards de dollars cette année
ils devaient augmenter à 5 milliard ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on réduit la vitesse
d'augmentation des versements pour
financer la baisse d'impôts mais
pourquoi on fait ça pour éviter que la
baisse d'impôts se fasse aux dépens des
services alors c'est vraiment un
équilibre métiers des services
financiers adéquatement réduction des
impôts continuer de réduire le poids de
la dette en maintenant les versements au
fonds des générations au moins je ne
voudrais qu'on une cagnotte qui
s'appelle le fonds des générations et de
tous les partis pige dedans en ce moment
on arrive en campagne électorale excusez
mais pige chez pas le bon terme parce
qu'on ne touche pas au fond
merci ont diversement vous réduisez mais
il ya des partis qui vont chercher tous
les versements le parti québécois aussi
on a parlé va chercher de l'argent dans
le fonds des générations dans les
versements au fonds des générations
c'est comme si le fonds des générations
qui est là pour réduire la dette
aujourd'hui sert à toutes sortes de
choses la transition énergétique d'un
côté les baisses d'impôts de votre côté
mais le fonds a été créé en 2006 à cette
époque le niveau d'endettement du québec
était beaucoup plus élevé on a fait des
progrès énormes alors ce qu'on prend
acte des progrès c'est indiqué dans le
rapport au pré électorale qu'on va
atteindre nos cibles que nous étions
fixés on ne nous sommes engagés à donner
une nouvelle cee'd à modifier les
versements au fonds des générations
est ce que nous indique on sait que la
dette nette par rapport au pib pour
passer de 38 à 31 % sur dix ans et que
la moyenne canadienne est à 30 euros
vous êtes économiste oui je ne suis pas
économiste mais vous savez mieux que moi
que de mettre 3 milliards 500 millions
d'un coup sec dans l'économie c'est
inflationnistes
ça dépend encore une fois il faut bien
séparer les éléments de notre programme
je pars de ce que vous avez reçues au
moment de ce que vous les versions
décembre impopulaire ici on parle de 600
$ pour quatre points six millions de
personnes qui gagnent moins de 59 ans et
pour 1.8 million de personnes en
cinquante mille cent mille ça vise à
compenser pour la consommation de base
un panier de consommation de base de 25
mille dollars l'indexation du régime
fiscal est de 2 pour 1 7% on l'inflation
va avoisiner 6 points 56.7 pour ça on
compense pour que les gens puissent donc
compenser les biens ce panier de
consommation d'eau de 25000 d'injecter
des milliards de dollars dans l'économie
en ce moment n'est pas inflationniste
pour vous non parce que ces gens là au
besoin de vêtements est ce que le
logement est un calibration mille cent
mille dollars ont besoin d'être stimulée
sur le plan économique je vous rappelle
les chiffres 4.8 millions de personnes
vont recevoir ses cymbales à ceux qui
ont moins de 59 1 pour 1 6 million de 50
mille cent mille vont recevoir 400 $
pour ça qu'on le moduler en fonction du
revenu on a pris acte des
recommandations nous a suggéré le
moduler en fonction du revenu c'est ce
qu'on fait ça va aider maintenant la
baisse d'impôt arrivant 2023 et en 2023
qu'est ce qui se passe on a un
ralentissement économique on prévoit
trois points 4 % cette année 1.7 pour ça
3.4 2022 1.7 2023 le stimulus fiscales
vont arriver exactement au bon moment en
2023 parfait si gérard c'est ce que nous
allons voir merci beaucoup merci merci